tous ceux qui l'invoquent utilise le nom
de vierges sanglante pas moi j'ai
effectué le rituel correctement c'est
pour ça qu'elle est apparue catharines
mais je comprends pas pourquoi elle
s'est échappée on va passer au plan
d'eau nos élèves est tombé en syncope
dans les toilettes
ils demandent à ce que vous interveniez
dans notre collège pour éliminer la
vierge sanglante quatre demeuraient qui
font un film d'horreur notre travail est
sérieux au nez des exterminateurs de
francs et des influenceurs d'affaires
n'est pas question que je suis encore
les fantômes tous ceux qui prennent les
fantômes au sérieux finisse comme toi je
crois que les enfants sont en danger
[Applaudissements]
la vierge entre tout ce que j'ai vu elle
est bien réelle
cette chose que vous avez dit viens d'un
autre manger quoi cette paix
non mais vous vous foutez de moi je n'ai
pas cette mère d'un mec comme mon
affaire
elle était possédé est-ce que je suis
obligé de me raser la barbe est ce
qu'une gamine de 13 ans à d'abord est-ce
qu'une gamine de 13 ans à une quête ses
fils de démons
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi je pense un box content
même si ça finit en eau de boudin ça ne
changera pas ma carrière quand est ce
que tu vas arrêter de traîner avec ces
bons à rien ban de greta
tout va bien se passer maintenant que
madame helena est là et tu crois ou chez
les bisounours dit merde
c'est pas la peine de me pousser
c'est pas la peine